we've known for a while that Donald
Trump is very insecure about his size
the size of his crowd at his events and
after Trump's inauguration the National
Park Service you might remember tweeted
the side-by-side picture
comparing Trump's 2017 crowd and Obama's
2009 crowd which of course the Obama
crowd on the left here if you're
watching with us and the Trump crowd on
the right and in response on
inauguration day the Trump
administration got the National Park
Service to delete the tweet and they
told them and the entire Department of
the Interior to immediately stop using
Twitter and this raised legitimate
safety concerns because the National
Park Service in the Department of the
Interior used Twitter to post emergency
messages to park visitors and to
communicate other breaking news of
breaking importance but the White
House's first priority was get rid of
the tweet temporarily shut down those
accounts at all costs the next day
presumably because of the Trump
administration's intervention the
National Park Service actually tweeted
an apology and that apology said we
regret the mistaken retweets from our
account yesterday and look forward to
continuing to share the beauty and
history of our parks with you that we
knew okay then what we have now learned
the news is that according to emails
released through a Freedom of
Information Act request Donald Trump was
personally and directly involved in
trying to hunt down the person the
specific person at the National Park
Service who was responsible for tweeting
and retweeting those photos one of the
emails between the head of social media
at the Park Service and their head of IT
reads quote this has become a very
sensitive issue especially since the
president has gotten directly involved
and contacted acting director Mike
Reynolds concerned about one of the
images that was retweeted they were
reporting historical facts about
important events called inaugurations
held at a national park and it was
almost by definition a witch-hunt saans
the literal witches with donald trump
involve trying to figure out who the
individual responsible was
Trump should get to the bottom of a lot
of tweets but they're mostly his own
tweets that we need to be figuring out
what's going on with and imagine if you
were just inaugurated as president and
the learning curve that you'd be facing
the amount of responsibilities you'd
have to take over right you this would
be in the back of your mind this is such
a trivial thing why is he drawing so
much attention to this in his first few
days in office first and second day in
office and this is what Donald Trump was
worried about making phone calls and
wondering what individual had the
audacity to retweet historically
accurate pictures about an event that
took place at a national park and the
thing is that Barack Obama's 2009
inauguration was the first inauguration
of a black president so people went
there also to witness history more so
than just to support their candidate
sure uh Donald Trump didn't have that
same draw and not to mention I mean I
think that you could Donald Trump's
inauguration might end up being historic
we'll know in a couple hundred years if
it was a turning point of sorts and and
a turning point for the worse in the
United States but yeah you're completely
right that it's not even necessarily
something to feel bad about if your
Trump you've got plenty to feel bad
about already the man with the nuclear
codes was spending time in the hours
after being sworn in trying to figure
out who tweeted inauguration pictures
and that should really scare all of us
today's program is sponsored in part by
tag adapt the hosting specialists who do
dedicated VPS and cloud server options
one of the great things about taga dab
is that their customer service is sort
of their forte 70% of their business
comes from repeat orders as well as from
recommendations from existing customers
and if you look them up on Trustpilot
you'll see that they're rating is nine
point seven out of ten which is
excellent they're also offering for
those interested in exploring moving
their business or their project or
website to the cloud a ten-pound free
credit to all new customers that sign up
at our link which is signup tag adapt
com forward slash TDPS that is signup ta
ga da bee
/td PS check it out support our sponsors
and support the david pakman show by
doing so